the holidays are a time for added cheer
and also a little added stress and that
often comes with increased alcohol
consumption according to UCLA health
alcohol consumption spikes between
Thanksgiving and the new year for some
people it doubles compared to the rest
of the year many Americans may fall
unknowingly into a category known as a
gray area of drinking Meg Oliver has
what you need to know
when I came up here I didn't know anyone
I was in the house it was a long day it
was a long day
with just me and the baby and you felt
isolated I did Maureen Anderson is a
married mother of four she says that
isolation is part of what led her to
drink more frequently it became less of
an out of the house
special occasion party thing to more of
a at the end of the day
time to have a glass of wine shut off my
brain relax
how did you like to drink you know when
I was making dinner I'd pour a glass of
wine and that lead to another glass of
wine yeah it could be a bottle of night
it could be a little more it could be
less I could take a night off Anderson
didn't consider herself an alcoholic but
a great area Drinker Dr Akash Shaw is
the chief of addiction medicine at
Jersey Shore University Medical Center
the term gray area Drinker means someone
who is drinking more than they'd
probably like but not so much that it's
causing external consequences yet is
this just another term for alcoholism I
think the term falls into this gray area
because it doesn't yet meet the medical
definitions of alcoholism but I think
that risk is there drinking Nationwide
is on the rise according to the Journal
of addiction medicine during the covet
pandemic lockdown drinking among women
increased more than 50 percent and for
women with children under five it shot
up more than 300 percent this is always
a time of year where more clients come
in nutritionist Jolene Park quit
drinking eight years ago this gray area
drinking Spectrum
she gave a Ted Talk on the subject
that's been viewed more than 350 000
times now she counsels people like
herself to stay away from the bottle by
eating healthy foods exercising and
natural relaxation techniques how do you
know if you're a gray area Drinker gray
area drinkers can and do stop drinking
it's very very characteristic they
um stop frequently and say you know they
have a night they wake up the next
morning and say I can't keep drinking
like this
Anderson has gone two years without a
drink and it's also now a Certified
Recovery coach helping other women what
do you want people to take away from
this I want women to know that they're
not alone that you know we're expected
to drink a lot
and and be okay with it and to deal with
it and to and to feel fine we really are
expected to drink a lot it's it's
everywhere
for CBS mornings I'm Meg Oliver
Fairfield Connecticut
that is fascinating it's really
interesting and I can see why uh
especially in the early days of the
lockdown when people we weren't sure
what work was going to look like anxiety
fear stress all of that contributing to
people saying hey you know what I
normally have a glass of wine at the end
of the day I'm gonna have maybe two or
three yeah then that bleeds into us
coming out of the pandemic and you still
have that happen but it's important to
also realize that like you know they
have that what was that saying if you
drink alone you're an alcoholic or
whatever the actual standard is for
alcoholism there is a gray area and it's
important to pay attention to it because
it should be a slippery slope yeah it's
interesting when you go to the doctor
and they say so how many drinks a week
do you have and you're like uh well you
always you don't know if you're in that
gray area you always put one
but the thing is you don't know if you
say three or four he's gonna say a week
and you're like no a month I meant you
know because you're a little you don't
know what that gray area is yeah uh
social drinking if you tell a doctor
that you're socially drinking every week
yeah that's probably not a good thing
and listen you know all jokes aside if
you feel like you're drinking too much
the New Year's around the corner right
it's a great time to set some
resolutions and maybe not drinking as
much and there are resources for people
who feel